j'aimerais commencer par vous présenter
quelqu'un d'encore plus mal habillée que
moi alors vous remarquerez outre
l'harmonie des couleurs
le tatouage mon corps m'appartient mais
qui est donc cette personne est ce un
punk qui a emprunté la garde-robe de sa
grand mère
est ce une ado du 16e qui veut faire la
rebelle non c'est notre ministre de la
santé marisol touraine sur le perron de
l'elysée et c'était l'année dernière
pour fêter les 40 ans de la loi veil de
la loi qui permet aux femmes de prendre
le contrôle de leur corps via
interruption volontaire de grossesse mon
corps m'appartient maintenant c'est
banal tout le monde le dit d'ailleurs
pour une fois l'assemblée nationale en
tiennent à voter une loi symbolique
pourrait approuver la loi veil c'est
banal puisque même les ministres selon
et à tous sur le bras or ce n'est pas
tout à fait vrai j'aimerais vous citer
quelques exemples un peu extrême voire
franchement choquant qui nous montrait
que pour beaucoup de personnes et dans
bien des circonstances
eh bien mon corps ne m'appartient pas
d'abord il ne m'appartient pas
lorsque je suis vivant je n'ai pas le
droit de louer mon ventre je n'ai pas
droit dans beaucoup de pays de vendre ma
sexualité
je n'ai pas le droit de définir moi même
le genre auquel j'appartiens puisque je
dois passer devant le médecin devant le
juge ont déclaré à l'état civil si je
suis homme femme ou autre je n'ai pas le
droit non plus d'en faire n'importe quoi
non corps par exemple je ne peux pas
faire ceci
alors vous aurez reconnu leonardo
dicaprio dans ce bel exercice de lens
hénin mais il en existe des versions un
peu moins chic notamment celle que
pratique et la belle commune de morsang
sur orge dans l'essonne
au début des années 90 le maire de
morsang sur orge a dit non quand même ça
ne serait pas possible
balancer des nains et donc il a interdit
le lancer de nains et qui a protesté
bon les lanceurs denain on pourrait
d'autres activités à faire le dimanche
sont revenus à la pêche formellement ce
sont les nains eux mêmes qui ont
protesté parce qu'il avait un gagne pain
et puis une certaine renommée à paraître
c'est apparemment un certain succès avec
les femmes et le conseil d'état dans la
rue morsang sur orge
les juristes connaissent bien a dit non
c'est interdit je ne peux pas non plus
faire n'importe quoi de mon corps pour
mourir je n'ai pas le droit de me faire
euthanasier mais je n'ai pas grand non
plus de me faire manger en 2001 un
ingénieur allemand charmant a posté une
annonce disant je cherche un volontaire
pour le manger
il a reçu un certain nombre de candidats
a fait une sélection peut-être quelques
interviews de nos derniers stades
et puis finalement il a trouvé bernd qui
était tout à fait d'accord
alors ils ont commencé d'abord par
découper le sexe de berne et un le
manger ensemble probablement aux
chandelles visiblement assez satisfait
de ce petit apéritif
ils ont décidé de passer à la suite et
d'ailleurs tout est filmé et donc on
peut le voir je vous recommande cette
très sympa armin à manger berne
et figurez vous que c'est interdit enfin
c'est incroyable il faut quand même de
mal à personne et ben non on n'a pas
droit de se faire manger
et même après la mort je ne peux pas
toujours faire n'importe quoi de mon
corps par exemple je n'ai pas le droit
de pratiquer l'immersion en mer alors
que le plongeon est autorisée du vivant
je n'ai pas le droit non plus de me
faire embaumer à moins que je m'appelle
lénine mao ou valéry giscard d'estaing
je n'ai pas le droit non plus il est
encore plus grave de me faire
cryogéniser cesser ces personnes qui se
font kiki qui se font gelé jusqu'en
congelés en espérant que dans dix ans
entend un million d'années on décongèle
parce qu'on aura trouvé les moyens de
les faire revivre
ou bien de guérir les maladies qui les
ont tués c'est un certain succès il ya
des en russie ou aux états unis des
bases de cryogéniser où vous pouvez voir
donc les cercueils alors certains
maîtres le corps entier d'autres
seulement la tête moins cher et en
france un médecin martineau appui que
j'ai trouvé que c'était une très bonne
idée d'abord fait congeler sa femme est
comme ça ça avait l'air de bien se
passer
il a décidé de la suivre dans la
congélation unis à jamais dans leur beau
de la comtesse et dans un château ou
comment toute cette histoire et puis
quelqu'un a découvert sain a porté
plainte recommence pas possible des gens
qui sont rangés dans le village c'est
quand même vous rendez compte est bon
leur fils leur fille celui était ravi
les voir de temps en temps c'est mieux
que se recueillir sur une tombe
hélas le conseil d'état le même conseil
d'état a dit ah non ça c'est pas
possible
vous aimez les décongeler les brûler
d'ailleurs tout ça au feu alors procédé
rabon et ben justice martin ont été
obligés de finalement brûlé ses parents
vous imaginez ces pauvres parti n'en qui
s'imaginent unis pour des millions
d'années les revivre dans un futur
sexualité totalement ouvert totalement
revivifier rajeunie et ben non c'est
maintenant d'un tas de cendres alors
derrière ces tragédies des tragédies ne
nous concerne pas tous il ne voulons pas
être mangés être congelés ou être lancée
bon
s'en fiche mais le problème c'est que ça
s'applique à chacun d'entre nous c'est
le code civil qui le dit par la loi de
bioéthique de 1994 les conventions enfin
vous pouvez lire ça veut dire quoi c'est
à dire qui a pas de propriété privée de
patrimonialité sur le corps parce qu'on
dit la personne est indisponible en
droit et donc le corps lui-même n'est
pas patrimoniale villa n'est pas la
propriété de votre propre corps on dira
ah bon ils me tueront france ont
interdit tous les biens aux etats-unis
les enseignements libéral c'est pareil
ça a été d'ailleurs marqué de manière
très claire dans un arrêt de la cour
suprême de californie
l'arrêt john moore alors john moore est
un patient qui souffrait d'une leucémie
dans les années 80 et les médecins ont
dû lui enlever la rate et ils ont
découvert que ces cellules avait des
vertus extraordinaires pour produire
certains types de protéines et donc les
médecins on extrait sans lui dire à john
moores plein de ces cellules ils ont
extrait du sang du sperme de moelle
épinière j'sais pas comment ils ont ils
y ont fait comprendre que pour salut
c'est me devait lui retirer du sperme
l'enfant seconde va pas et ils en ont
fait une lignée cellulaire la lignée de
jeanne moreau qu'ils ont revendu des
centaines de milliers de dollars à des
grandes institut pharmaceutique et john
moores quand il s'est aperçu le rsa
perçu cette supercherie a dit attendez
moi j'ai pas quelque chose là dedans
quand même cellule
excusez moi et donc ça fait un immense
procès et le juge a conclu que non ce
n'était pas ses cellules qu'est-ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas la propriété de ces
cellules
alors d'où est ce que ça vient tout ça
bien ya de bonnes raisons quand même
pour croire que ça vient de l'héritage
des grands monothéismes cette idée
saint-paul le corps et pour le seigneur
des seigneurs pour le corps que dans les
grands monothéismes et en particulier
dans les religions judéo-chrétiennes
mon corps ne m'appartient pas parce
qu'il appartient à dieu encore est le
reflet de l'esprit juste en attaque un
corps et leur fait l'esprit mon esprit
mon âme est immortel rejoint le royaume
des cieux est d'ailleurs je peux même
aller à la résurrection
s'il en est que le conseil d'état ne m'a
pas fait brûler et d'ailleurs le pape
pie xii l'a dit de manière extrêmement
explicite sa première fois que le city
guide vous entrerez en public en 1954
devant un congrès de médecins où il a
expliqué que l'homme n'est que
l'usufruitier de son corps et non pas
son possesseur plein et entier alors
dans notre droit séculaire sécularisée
n'est plus question de dieu et bien le
concept de dieu a été remplacé par le
concept de dignité
ça paraît toujours morsang sur orge
c'est pour cette raison que le conseil
d'état a interdit le lancer de nains
parce que le dignité de la personne
humaine est regardé comme un composant
de l'ordre public ça veut dire que c'est
aujourd'hui cette transcendance qu'on a
aboli transcendance divine et reprise
par l'état par la société si vous voulez
qui définit la dignité de chacun donc la
dignité c'est le sacré sans dieu l'idée
que quand même le corps c'est sacré on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi alors moi
je vous propose d'essayer d'aller au
bout de la logique de la modernité et si
on était vraiment complètement dans
l'immanence à qui appartient le corps
sinon à moi-même qui peut définir
satellite et sinon moi même d'abord voir
c'est ce qu'a fait john locke pas john
moore john locke ses moyens beaucoup de
jeunes john locke key le premier voit
écrit à ma connaissance que chacun avait
la propriété de sa propre personne c'est
par hasard si c'est lui écrit ça parce
que john locke était médecin mais c'est
bien la chaire réactions du corps et
aussi parce que il était en plein dans
la glorieuse révolution britannique la
révolution dépit d'offres ait donc tout
cette théorie sur le contrat social sur
les trois premiers et fondamentaux sur
la résistance civile
c'est aussi le fait de dire que j'ai des
droits naturels qui préexiste donc droit
de propriété de moi même il ya les vues
plus loin dit
je peux avoir la propriété sur des
choses extérieures si je peux
m'approprier le monde en le travaillant
en y ajoutant de la valeur
cette idée de propriété est d'abord née
de l'appropriation de moi-même et
réfléchissez dit si on a la propriété du
corps on a suivant les termes classique
blues housse lui font tousser labousse
loose ou c'est à dire toujours mais un
alternateur l'eau douce ces deux usages
donc si j'ai douze du corps et bien les
nains peuvent exercer leur profession
pigments ensuite le faut que tous le
faire fructifier et donc john moore pour
toucher l'argent de ces cellules et puis
il abuse je peux en abuser en faire ce
que je veux si je veux cryogénisé c'est
mon problème
exemple que la nouvelle génération est
une génération qui refuse les structures
préconçues veut définir son propre
métier qui veut définir sa propre vie en
voyageant qui veut se construire ce
procédé soit mettre le créateur de
semaine et on peut voir de manière un
peu anecdotique sociologique à quel
point cette génération s'approprie son
corps par le tatouage par exemple ceux
ci la manière de définir sa sexualité de
manière beaucoup plus fluide d'étudier
sortie qui montrait que la génération z
ça m'a plu white êtes maintenant si on a
une génération post genre c'est même
plus que l'ebit c'est que elle définit
sa chacun définit sa propre sexualité
avec un peu de ceci et de cela alors ça
donne beaucoup de choses
par exemple on peut être 2000 sexuelle
gris sexuelle giné sexuelle penser qu
suel strauss kahn sectionnant ça
enfin bon il ya plein de versions donc
je connais pas tout je veux pas
tellement les dégâts sur scène et c'est
intéressant et plus fondamentalement ça
va nous permettre de traiter les trois
grands sujets de l'avenir le sujet
de l'homme augmenté de l'augmentation de
soi le sujet du transhumanisme et le
sujet des dates à des données si demain
je peux et je peux déjà augmenté c'est à
dire construire des bras artificiel
augmenter les membres augmenter ma
capacité cérébrale voir modifier ma
propre adn
si je modifierai propre adn je dois bien
en être propriétaire
si demain je veux tester je vais essayer
l'immortalité soit par la cryogénisation
voilà cet exemple sympathique qui
revient soit par exemple comme
l'imaginent récuse weill le pape du
transhumanisme en transférant ma
conscience sur une clé usb est bien de
même je vais finir moi même même
contractuellement ce qui de la manière
dont mon corps est liée au monde
et puis il ya une troisième grande
question qui peut paraître un peu
adjacentes qui est la question des
données la question des datas les data
on en produit vous savez énormément et
leur valeur est gigantesque puisque en
europe on estime que elle vaudra 1000
milliards d'euros d'ici 2020 or ces data
qui va le temps d'argent avec lesquels
des groupes font tant d'argent et bien
vos données personnelles ne vous
appartiennent pas de même qu'il n'ya pas
de patrimonialité d'aidé du corps il
n'ya pas patrimonialité des données
exactement pour la même raison parce que
les données sont considérés comme le
reflet de votre personnalité et que l'on
a vu en droit la personnalité est
inaliénable et le corps n'est pas
patrimoniale
si demain nous trouvons nous pouvons
construire une propriété privée des data
qui sera à l'ère digitale ce que la
propriété intellectuelle fut à la
révolution industrielle
alors vous deviendrez propriétaire en
termes véritablement juridique financier
de vos données que vous pourrez négocier
en d'autres termes
enfin vous serez payé pour les sur
facebook alors mon corps m'appartient
ce n'est pas une banalité fait un
tatouage que finalement on devrait on
devrait tous porter parce que la toute
nouvelle génération eh bien ce sont des
sujets qu'elle va devoir affronter le
transhumanisme arrivent les comités de
bioéthique
très rapidement sont déjà dépassés et
pour que chacun puisse choisir ses
propres valeurs
dans cet univers complexe et bien nous
devons d'abord posséder notre propre
corps merci